pas yann dubois merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre des affaires sociales et de
la santé
j'ai appris hier en fin d'après-midi par
les médias une bien triste nouvelle la
fermeture de la maternité pithiviers je
suis très déçu et contrarié me suis
battu sans relâche aux côtés du
personnel des habitants et aux côtés de
nombreux élus pour le maintien de cette
maternité si cher dans le coeur des
nord-loire est un il est inadmissible
que cette maternité qui assurait encore
plus de 500 naissances par an soit
sacrifiée dorénavant les femmes auront
de 45 minutes à 1h30 de trajet pour
aller donner la vie c'est la disparition
d'un nouveau service de santé de
proximité la fermeture de notre
maternité n'est pas un cas isolé dans
nos territoires ruraux
c'est une conséquence de la politique de
santé mise en place par le gouvernement
là où il y avait en train dé cohésion
dans nos communautés hospitalières
c'est une concurrence exacerbée qui
s'installe entre les établissements pour
leur survie à travers des j'ai acheté
dans le même temps les agences
régionales de santé ars organisatrice de
la politique de soins sur les
territoires se limite à un rôle de
spectateur et de liquidateurs madame le
ministre vous avez reçu vous nous avez
reçu avec le sénateur sueur jeudi
dernier à votre ministère en indiquant
que toutes les pistes restent est à
l'étude
moins d'une semaine après c'est la
fermeture qui est décidé madame la
ministre vous avez déclaré vouloir
préserver dans la durée les hôpitaux
locaux de proximité et donner de la
force au petit établissement un de vos
lointains prédécesseurs bernard kouchner
avait lui fait le déplacement 97 pour
annoncer la fermeture de cette maternité
avant de faire en sorte qu'elle puisse
ouvrir à nouveau neuf mois plus tard
allez vous suivre ce précédent
allez-vous prendre effectivement la
mesure des difficultés que nous
rencontrons pour le recrutement des
professionnels
allez-vous demander aux ars de remplir
le rôle d'organisation de la politique
de santé ou les conforter dans le rôle
de bureaux d'enregistrement des
fermetures d'établissements
il a parlé quand madame ségolène
neuville secrétaire d'état chargé des
personnes handicapées et de la lutte
contre l'exclusion
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés et madame la
députée marianne dubois je tiens tout
d'abord à excuser la ministre de la
santé marisol touraine qui est en
déplacement dans le finistère de la
députée ce gouvernement est attaché plus
qu'aucun autre auparavant au maintien
d'une offre hospitalière de proximité
partout en france
nous avons par exemple décidé de mieux
financer les hôpitaux locaux les
hôpitaux isolé via le projet de loi de
finance vous pouvez vous en souvenir
nous mettons actuellement en place les
groupes hospitaliers de territoires qui
sont destinées à maintenir les filières
de soins
j'aimerais savoir comment la mise en
place des groupes hospitaliers
territoire qui n'est même pas encore
effectives a pu condamner la maternité
de pithiviers comme vous venez de le
déclarer
nous mettons en place des mesures
incitatives pour attirer les médecins
hospitaliers et les médecins libéraux
dans les zones sous-dotées parfois
malheureuses pour coacher l'équipe
médicale nécessaire ne parvient pas à
être constituées de manière stable
comme pour la maternité de pithiviers
alors que des efforts considérables ont
été déployés pour réussir et là quelle
est notre responsabilité
notre responsabilité c'est avant tout de
garantir à chaque femme qui accouche les
conditions de sécurité maximum
oui il y a effectivement deux exigences
essentielles proximité mais aussi
sécurité
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé à
pithiviers à pithiviers c'est l'hôpital
lui-même à la suite d'un événement
indésirable grave qui a enclenché la
procédure de fermeture et je vous le
redis aucun poste n'a été supprimé et
aucune mesure d'économie n'a été
demandée c'est la difficulté à recruter
des médecins et assurer le
fonctionnement normal de la maternité
qui a obligé l'agencé régionale de santé
à prendre cette décision
marisol touraine nous a indiqué sa
volonté d'aider fortement l'hôpital de
bêtisiers et bien c'est la réalité
un centre périnatal de proximité ouvrira
pour assurer le suivi des femmes avant
et après leur accouchement et le service
aujourd'hui madame la ministre à pied la
parlait comme